hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 7 video
we're only a couple weeks away from the
mid-season finale and we got a big WTF
reveal it looks like we're basically in
the homestretch in terms of wrapping up
this big Tahiti mystery right now I
think episode 9 is gonna be the last one
before they cut for the mid-season break
and remember agent Carter is gonna start
in January that'll run for eight
episodes and then shield will come back
for the rest of the episodes for the
second half of the season but careful
for spoilers if you're not cut up on
agents of shield so starting with top
five moments number five ward on the run
or beardless Ward on the run the beard
survived for the entire episode but I'm
not surprised they gave it the in credit
sequence treatment usually that's
reserved for like the big WTF reveals
but they push the blueprint for the
beard that just gives you an idea of how
important the writers think it is and
how important they think Ward's
character is to be fair the amount of
time we've spent with him the first half
of the season has led us to believe or
misled us in thinking that he's not that
important don't be fooled though during
interviews the writers often talk about
how Ward is such an interesting
character to write for it's just they
haven't been ready to tell his story yet
he's tied up with Skye's father the
diviner and the Whitehall plot so as
that comes to a head of the mid-season
finale he'll become a much bigger
character number four the mystery man is
out murdering other test subjects just
to explain the reason he was murdering
people wasn't because he hated them it
was because he needed to see the final
piece of the puzzle you know that 3d
puzzle they saw at the end and he just
didn't have that information he thought
that the other people knew and they had
forgotten because he thought that pain
was a way to remember he just gave them
pain hoping that they would remember
it's kind of tragic I don't know if
we're gonna see him again they turned
him over to the authorities it's
possible he could show up again based on
his character's background it sounds
like he was a prime candidate for Hydra
so it's possible that Hydra could do
something with him
his name is Sebastian Derik but he's the
only other person besides the core
shield team members that have seen the
city I think it's pretty easy to assume
that the diviner is connected to the
city so obviously at some point Hydra is
going to make a race for it number three
Coulson straps himself into rayna's
machine again I had almost forgotten
about it till they started talking about
it I thought it was a normal MRI machine
until they referenced last season and
then it kind of clicked in my brain in
reality it was the under
Tahiti base where they were conducting
experiments on the GHD I think by now we
all know that that's a Cree there but
the interesting thing is we actually get
a lot of information in this whole
flashback sequence we learned that the
alien is thousands of years old predates
the pyramids meaning that the city that
it was trying to get to also predates
the pyramids if any of you read the
comics they just got done doing the
original sin storyline
I feel like Coulson's storyline would
have fit into that perfectly just the
horrible things that he put all the test
subjects through making them forget
putting in that creepy looking matrix
machine fixing their memories for those
that didn't read that comic book the
original sin' comic book it's actually
really good you should check it out but
it's basically a bunch of heroes
remember awful things that they did from
the past
speaking of awful things number two Ward
captures box key for Coulson Ward is
being sly but this was what was
happening he went to an old Hydra
hangout called Hydra as if he was gonna
give them information on Coulson but
then double-crossed them so he's a
double-crossing double-crosser meaning
that you can trust absolutely zero of
what he says which is funny because he
told Skye that he'd never lied to her I
don't really know what to do with that I
still don't think we can trust him I
think he's gonna do something really
creepy he's gonna be the cat that leaves
dead birds on the doorstep that was one
of my favorite lines from the episode
all the Skyward lines especially when
she picked up the phone and said hail
Hydra I would totally do that if that
wasn't like a six-month-old thing to do
I feel like at this point people were
getting sick of people saying hail Hydra
like the meme has run its course
don't worry age of Ultron next year will
probably give us some new crazy Marvel
meme and my number one WTF moment of
course the map is not a map it's a
blueprint for a city so I'm just gonna
say what we're all thinking here Attilan
Inhumans I've suggested this in the past
but we've never had compelling evidence
till right now like it was always just a
theory like if it's a map to a place
maybe it's a map to the city of the
Inhumans although technically that's not
what it is in reality it's a blueprint
of the city itself
like it's a map of the city so many
things in the episode had been building
up to a big reveal the minute we saw
that Train Set I knew it would probably
be the final piece of the puzzle how
convenient that the villain ran up the
stairs and Coulson had to chase him so
that they could get an aerial shot I
felt like that was a little force but I
totally get it they needed to see it
from above so they had to have a reason
to run up the stairs
the only thing I was disappointed about
was the fact that their craziness is
gone like now that they've seen it and
they know what it is they're not going
nuts anymore I kind of like crazy
Coulson I could just felt it added a
nice dimension to the character but he
said it at the end of the episode Hydra
is looking for the city too even though
we haven't got a scene with Hydra
talking about a city specifically Skye's
father is really the back door to that
he'll explain the diviner to Whitehall
we haven't seen a scene about that yet
so we'll probably at that next week then
Whitehall will learn about the city then
they'll try to get there before Coulson
so just to lead into what's happening
next week in the week after they're
really there two episodes left in this
first half of the season next week's
episode number eight is called things we
bury it features another agent Carter
flashback with Hayley Atwell I have no
idea what it's gonna be about probably
has something to do with that blue alien
from Tahiti the description the synopsis
of the episode is also teasing a Hydra
confrontation but episode 9 the actual
mid-season finale at least I think it's
the mid-season finale is called ye who
enter here so it makes it seem like
they're gonna find the door to the city
even if they don't go in I feel like
that would be a moment for them to leave
on like either the end credits scene or
the very end of the episode they just
walk through the door they see it and
then BAM it cuts to black and then we
have to wait till next year to figure
out what the city is all about with that
in mind I will try to do some more
Inhumans bonus videos stuff about
Attilan that's the actual name of the
city of the Inhumans for people that
haven't read the comics so be sure to
subscribe to get all that stuff I've
already done an Inhumans movie video so
I'll add a link in the description if
you want to watch that it's actually a
really interesting thought you think
that they would wait for a movie to
introduce the Inhumans if they do end up
doing it on agents of shield I'll
totally give Marvel props it just gives
you an idea of how much they value
agents of shield and yes there will be
crossovers with age of Ultron I think
Coulson and Triplett are confirmed I
don't know who else there might be other
agents let me know that what was your
favorite moment from the episode and do
you agree do you think that the city
that they're talking about is Attilan
city of the Inhumans overall I gave the
episode a solid b-plus just for teasing
even just teasing that they might be
doing Inhumans on TV I was a little
disappointed that they kind of explained
away the psychosis so quickly like
they're homing pigeons and they just
didn't know where home was I was just
hoping to see more crazy Coulson just
because Clark Gregg is so great at
playing that type of character normally
he's so calm and
collected so emotionless so whenever he
does do emotional things it's just a
really big deal
Ward is totally of course my favorite
bad guy in the show right now even
though I'm kind of hoping to see more of
Whitehall especially the second half of
the season I feel like after we get past
the big WTF reveal of whatever this city
is gonna be then then we'll spend some
more time with the bigger villains that
we haven't seen as much of namely Skye's
father and Whitehall I just I love the
fact that they've been teasing so much
of the monster under the surface like
underneath people's skin I'm really
hoping that someone actually turns into
a real-life monster for anyone that
hasn't read the Inhumans comics it's all
about the Terrigen mist you take it in
and it either gives you superpowers or
it kills you it's like it unlocks your
evolutionary potential that doesn't mean
that everyone's just gonna start growing
third limbs and stuff on the show but
I'm just I'm really hoping this guy's
father actually turns into a real-life
monster just because he seems so crazy
already
even if people aren't quite as crazy as
I want them to be like closin for
instance I do feel like Shields has done
an amazing job of building momentum all
season that is really the job of a TV
show to just continually build tension
until it explodes at the mid-season
finale that being said it's putting a
lot of pressure on itself
I mean shield made a lot of promises in
this episode you have a blue crea lien
mysterious code a device that might or
might not be a Terrigen crystal in a
potential introduction to one of
Marvel's biggest franchises that has not
been seen in a movie yet just to be
clear though if we do end up seeing at
Ilyn in the Inhumans in the mid-season
finale or even in the second half of the
season I don't think we're gonna see
black bolts or Medusa or any of the main
characters I think they would save
something like that for the movies I
know everyone wants Vin Diesel to be
Black Bolt like that's what the rumor is
right now but it's not confirmed and the
Inhumans movie isn't gonna be till one
of like the later phase three movies so
it's still a long ways off they haven't
cast anyone yet in the meantime in case
you haven't seen it you can click here
for my agents of shield episode 6 video
I also explained a lot of the Marvel
phase 3 movies in that video too and you
can click here for my episode 5 video
thank you so much for watching so let's
all high five and I'll see you guys
tonight
you